nathalie provost qui est diplômé de
polytechnique à montréal survivants des
porte-parole de police se souvient vous
êtes avec nous pour discuter de ce
projet de loi bonjour bonjour vous avez
été blessé par l'arm de marc lépine en
1989 lorsque vous entendu le premier
ministre trudeau un peu plus tôt
aujourd'hui annoncé que c'était terminé
au canada ce type d'armes d'assaut
militaire comment est ce que vous avez
réagi
cette promesse lors l'attend depuis 30
ans en fait c'est pas de promesses qu'on
attend c'est la décision donc c'est une
décision avec laquelle on est très très
contents
il était plus que temps que des
décisions de cette nature là qu'ils
soient prises et pour nous je me
souviens encore de la conférence de
presse qu étudiante à laquelle j'ai
participé étudiants à 1990 en janvier
j'étais aux côtés d'eric on a entendu
quelques minutes et on demandait déjà la
position que ce soit ben ali des armes
comme celle qu'avait utilisé à marquer
puis non je suis très très contente de
cette décision là ce que je souhaite
c'est qu'on aille jusqu'au bout de deux
de la promesse et que c'est en bleu ne
puisse plus être utilisé au canada ne
soit plus en circulation que nos
concitoyens ne lisez plus parce que tu
peux y arriver des codes de vol il peut
y arriver dès qu on va pas bien et tout
à coup tout bascule dans nos vies on a
envie de commenter gestion pas de penser
et c'est associe qu'on veut se protéger
parce que vous êtes consciente que c'est
pas parce que le gouvernement
aujourd'hui interdit la vente
l'importation l'achat de ces armes là
dans le positif que ces armes là ne
peuvent pas venir au canada et être
utilisé par quelqu'un de malveillant a
fait elles le sont déjà au canada et
s'est passé des dizaines et des dizaines
de milliers de copies de ces armes blocs
qui sont au canada et
et qu'en effet de nos concitoyens ont
achetées en toute légalité avec tous les
permis requis
le fait que nos lois lamal la manière
dont nos lois sont faites il ya des gens
qui ont acquis en toute bonne foi ces
armes là et si on considère désormais
qu'elles ne peuvent plus être vendus ici
qu'elles ne doivent plus être accessible
à nos citoyens belle question de que
font tout ce qu'ils ont et qu'est ce
qu'on fait de tout ce qu'ils ont et
comment on s'y prend pour qu'il n'y ait
plus de ces melons en circulation au
canada
c'est une question sérieuse auquel on
s'attendait à une réponse plus ferme et
plus forte aujourd'hui
donc vous n'êtes pas tellement d'accord
avec la période d'amnistié qu'il va
jusqu'au 31 avril 2020 si la justice ne
vaut que jusqu'au 30 avril 2002 et
qu'elle est belle se poursuit avec un
programme d'un rachat sérieux et
disciplinés on peut comprendre et c'est
une chose de prendre une décision la
mise en oeuvre peut demander du temps on
en est conscient mais on veut une mise
en oeuvre et on veut une réflexion
sérieuse savoir sur comment on va faire
pour retirer effectivement toutes les
armes sont aujourd'hui en circulation
on ne bouchez le bout de chou blanc le
tuyau est bouché à l'entrée de la
piscine est plein il faut vider la
piscine
bon comment vous expliquez que ça a pris
30 oct
il fallait attendre trente ans après
polytechnique bon qu'elle presque deux
semaines après la nouvelle écosse entre
ça il ya eu beaucoup de suri au canada
comment expliquer que sa prise entend
convaincre nos gouvernements à agir de
manière vraiment ferme et décisive
là la discussion sur les armes à feu
dans notre nain dans notre pays est
d'abord une discussion politique avant
d'être une discussion de sécurité
publique et à mon avis tout l'enjeu est
là donc on calcule des votes
on essaie de permis de faire plaisir à
tout le monde on essaie de protéger les
intentions de tout un chacun
on le voit aussi sa polarise énormément
les positions on a qu'à voir la position
du de l'opposition il ya effectivement
des choses qui sont à faire en matière
de contrôle des armes à feu et qui te
qui touche la la excusez-moi j'ai que le
mot anglais qui me vient du coeur mais
il faut travailler mais la contrebande
mais c'est beaucoup
donc il faut absolument agir sur
plusieurs plans mais ba lire un type
dames c'est une pierre angulaire
importante qui est difficile à faire
mais je crois qu'il faut le faire ça
n'empêche pas la chasse ça n'empêche pas
le titre sportif ça n'empêche pas la
collection dame
ça fait juste dire que ce type d'armes
lors est conçu pour tuer qui conçu pour
tuer beaucoup et rapidement on ne veut
pas ça dans nos rues on ne veut pas ça
pour que nos enfants sont en contact
avec ça on ne veut pas le risque qui est
que ces occasions de cette étable
nathalie provost vous qui avez vécu
l'horreur l'enfer le cauchemar du 6
décembre 1989
vous vous sentez comme femme aujourd'hui
ou comme citoyenne plus en sécurité
un peu un peu là quand on quand on se
sert des événements comme les événements
de polytechnique pour juste fils
contrôler les armes à feu on souhaite
que de tels événements n'arrive plus
jamais or ce qui provoque un événement
comme ce qui est arrivé du jour en
nouvelle écosse
comme ce que j'ai vécu ya 30 ans
s'étonne c'est une multitude de facteurs
l'engagement des étudiants de
polytechnique qui aujourd'hui on n'est
plus des étudiants on est des adultes
mais les étudiants sont encore auprès de
nous engager
on est là parce que l'un de ces facteurs
là c'est l'instrument qui est utilisée
pour commettre des dommages donc et et
moi je m'engage parce que je crois que
si au moins on peut faire un peu avec
l'instrument mais on va avoir une chance
de réveiller des risques plus jamais
j'aimerais beaucoup jeu
suis honnête avec vous après trente
aujourd'hui chez une femme adulte en
pleine maturité
je crois qu'il va y avoir encore
d'autres drames et je crois que ce qu'on
vit aujourd'hui comme la pandémie ne
rendent pas le risque de drames moindre
au contraire on risque d'être dans une
société plus fragiles et dans une
société plus fragiles
si on a moins d'objets très dangereux à
notre portée moi je pense qu'on a notre
sécurité globale
alors qu'on minimise le risque ça c'est
certain nouveau merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous et bonne chance pour la
suite bon courage merci monsieur qui a
su temps voir